In conclusion the most Christmas movie is the
movie with factually, mathematically the most
Christmas. I hear you i see where you're coming
from however counterpoint a Christmas movie need
not invoke the trappings of Christmas or even the
spirit of Christmas and that's why spring breakers
is the most Christmas movie i feel like you're
stretching things a little thin with that one
maybe maybe a skosh thin thinner than the last
smear of frosting on the final gingerbread man
you know like after you're basically out of
icing but you still only have one cookie left
dan it's that then okay sure but consider for a
moment that what truly defines a Christmas movie
isn't the tinsel or reindeer
the fur trees or plum pudding
charity carols or ghosts of Christmas
past a Christmas movie is a movie that
we watch at Christmas that film that we put
on every year because it brings us together
you know that's a really beautiful point
dan thanks i stole it from your video
what is a Christmas movie nobody knows not
really and i'm not being snide because at the
root of it a Christmas movie is defined by social
consensus and social consensus is a nebulous thing
constantly shifting as opinions push and pull at
it a comprehensive taxonomy of Christmas movies is
impossible it can't be done even if they appear to
be as pristine and unimpeachable as this a by-axis
grid sorting movies along the axes of candy cane
and Christmas spirit organized from purist to
radical the target is constantly shifting you can
try but you'll never fully capture the breadth of
what people treat as a Christmas movie i know it
seems unbelievable that a system as superficially
flawless as the 3x3 morality grid could actually
be lacking but it's true even this system
brilliant inspired divine as it may be will still
generate pointless circular twitter arguments
about movies at the fringes don't forget to tag
your arguments with the hashtag candycane radical
the trick is that you'll never fully capture the
breadth of what people treat as a Christmas movie
because it's not just a categorization exercise
you're not just tracking wild reindeer who are
otherwise oblivious to the efforts and intentions
of humans you're asking questions of humans and
humans are aware of the efforts and intentions
of humans it's actually an opposed system and
some of the participants are deliberately trying
to confuse the process in the spirit of Christmas
we can illustrate this using toys some competitive
games like magic the gathering or league of
legends use a draft format where opponents take
turns selecting options from a finite pool this
format opens up a strategy called counter-picking
where you take an option not strictly because it's
something you want but because of how it will
impact the choices available to the opponent
maybe it's strong against something they've chosen
or maybe it combos well with their pick and so you
take it purely so they can't even if you have no
intention of using it it is a response not to the
immediate state of the game but to the idea of the
game itself a decision on making decisions i bring
it up just to illustrate that people are aware
that they're being asked questions that their
answers will potentially impact outcomes when we
are asked what's your favorite Christmas movie
we are conscious of the fact that there are
stereotypical answers that our answers will
reflect on our sensibilities and that other people
will potentially react to our pick and this meta
knowledge impacts the way that we pick our answers
some people give answers that are most true to
them some people give answers that they think
others want to hear and some people give answers
that they believe will confound the question
it is a counter pick a meta decision choosing
something that technically adheres to the taxonomy
but in subversive if not deliberately tenuous
ways knowing that the answers are ultimately
tautological Die Hard has become the ur example
here it is a story that takes place at Christmas
because it makes sense within the story for the
criminals to do their heist when everyone is busy
with Christmas eve but otherwise has little to do
with Christmas it wasn't even considered to
be a defining element of the film's identity
as the film was originally released in july
also the b plot is about a cop who killed a kid
harnessing the power of Christmas to regain the
confidence to shoot people again is that weird
that feels weird in fact the fascination with
whether or not Die Hard is a Christmas movie
itself an annual argument at this point
is largely a product of the last decade
so when asked what's your favorite Christmas
movie you answer oh it's Die Hard because
as an answer it's funny the person gets offended
a Christmas movie is wholesome but you picked
something full of cussing and violence you scamp
funny thing is it's worked Christmas movies defy
comprehensive classification because they are
self-defining Christmas movies are the movies
people say are Christmas movies and thus if
enough people say Die Hard is their favorite
Christmas movie then it is a Christmas movie this
is the unending taxonomic negotiation that makes
a comprehensive definition impossible some people
will always want to trick the system but this
raises an important question should these kinds of
counterpicks be excluded should we go out of our
way to exclude Die Hard because we know why people
are picking it on one hand they meet the classical
definition of trolling a deliberately inflammatory
choice that prods at the edges of definitions
on the other hand what's your favorite Christmas
movie is an inherently trivial exercise with
non-existent stakes so maybe to answer that
question we need to take it a step further why
do people troll these conversations and what do we
gain or lose if we take the answers authentically
i think the answer there is in belonging Christmas
is a complicated holiday it is both a high holy
day for most of the christian faith competing
with easter in its significance and it is also
the central holiday of the secular world of course
that relationship is not coincidental the one
following from the other and neither was always
the case the significance of Christmas in
christianity has fluctuated over the centuries
and the secular observance is derived from the
christian tradition explicitly a secularization of
the holiday thus the two holidays called Christmas
are codependent nigh inseparable with iconography
and traditions constantly interchanging to the
point that for many the two are the same Christmas
is monolithic in our culture in a way few things
are even capable of being and people have
interesting relationships with monoliths
cultural monoliths are things that persist beyond
the scope of a human lifetime binding generations
together they are things that are so ingrained
into the world that they feel like they've
always been there that they are self-evident
now it's not a novel observance that traditions
tie people together across generations but in this
case i think that's maybe missing the trees for
the forest don't get me wrong the big picture
is important feeling connected to history is
important but it's maybe sacrificing the immediate
value for the more poetic answer i want to make
an argument here in favour of tradition without
strictly arguing for traditionalism because many
traditional societal stances are harmful hurtful
deliberately exclusionary punitive and oppressive
there is sometimes an understandable instinct
to reject everything even superficially related
traditionalism is the argument that things are
per se good because they are traditional again
another tautology and that's not what i'm saying
here i don't think traditions or ritual are in any
way above criticism but i think it's good to have
traditions to have rituals because of what they
do for the individual ritual is valuable because
ritual is an outward signifier of stability in
order to observe ritual particularly ones tied to
a specific time of year then you need to be stable
enough to keep track of the year and you need
the time and space to observe the ritual thus the
ritual observance is a performance of stability
when people on twitter talk about self-care this
is often the instinct that they are pointing at
small personal rituals that reclaim time from
inhumane systems i am going to stand in this warm
shower until the hot water runs out and there is
nothing my boss can do to stop me humans are very
bad at experiencing time a year has no innate
meaning to our bodies and traditions help anchor
us as many people have learned during the pandemic
of 2020 life without temporal anchors gets weird
and depressing it is not psychologically good for
you they are things to look forward to things to
look back on and large social traditions provide a
common reference point for us to calibrate
ourselves around and in our society Christmas
is that monolithic reference point this is where
we get into the dueling desires of the human
psyche the need to be different unique independent
but also welcome and accepted the want for
space that we define but for that space to be part
of a whole the instinct to reject social ritual
paired with a desire to see oneself reflected
in social ritual people counter-pick Christmas
movies because they don't want to just adopt the
hegemonic Christmas they don't want Christmas to
just be served to them they want Christmas but
on their own terms so should the troll answers
be excluded should the counterpicks be ignored
well in a way it doesn't matter it's not the movie
that's actually important it's the argument itself
that's the ritual it's a way of staking a claim
to a shared social experience this is a social
negotiation process a series of pressures within
and without the definitions of society pushing to
create or deny the space for existence the space
to belong it's a negotiation far older than Die
Hard far older than movies older than Christmas
and it'll be around long after all of us are gone
so from all of us at folding ideas and film joy
whether it's Die Hard or It's a Wonderful
Life, Batman Returns or a Christmas Carol
may your ritual debate of what's really
a Christmas movie be filled with cheer.